making the most of our water that is the
goal of the Colorado River water users
Association conference happening this
week at Caesar's Palace and the
association is a non-profit made up of
nearly a thousand members from seven
states sharing the Colorado River Mary
Jane beliesza explains the efforts
Southern Nevada is the most water
secured City in the desert Southwest
just in the last year the water district
tied water restrictions John Ensminger
is the general manager of Southern
Nevada Water Authority and a speaker at
this year's conference this is a river
that's in crisis everybody that lives
here can see the bathtub ring around
Lake Mead but you know some of the other
40 million Americans that were lap on
the river don't really realize how bad
things are out on the river Nathan Allen
is the executive director of water start
a local non-profit finding several
technological ways to extend water use
one of the examples of technology that
we're working with here in southern
Nevada is a technology that uses
artificial intelligence to in real time
plan out how water moves across the city
so you can make sure you keep the cost
of energy as low as you can while
maintaining the quality of the water
inside of the pipe those are benefits
that come back to the ratepayer and
having more safer cheaper water in the
city other Alternatives in the works
includes reducing evaporative cooling
like swamp coolers and finding
cost-effective ways to reduce that water
without raising your electric bill so
they build large cooling towers and that
water evaporates out into the air
doesn't get returned to Lake Mead so
that we can reuse it again and sminger
says this type of collaboration is
crucial to develop strategies and
address Water Management challenges this
is a situation we've been preparing for
for the last 20 years this isn't
sneaking up on us we have added 780 000
new residents to Southern Nevada since
2002 and we're using 26 percent of less
water than we were 20 years ago so we've
proven that you can grow your economy
you can add new people but you can also
use less water
to date Lake Mead levels have dropped
more than 170 feet since it was last
full that was back in 1983.